[Music]
hey there everybody and welcome to
Gamespot presents now playing today
we're going to check out a really cool
PlayStation 4 game called counterspy
courtesy of David and Grace guys thank
you so much for joining us on the show
yeah pleasure to be here thank you all
right so counter spy is a game that's
been getting some pretty good Buzz
lately um but for anybody out there
who's maybe not heard of it anybody
who's not really familiar with it David
can you give us the kind of like basic
gist of what the game does yeah uh so
cpy is a sidescrolling action stealth
game uh set during the Cold War uh it's
very much our fictional take on the Cold
War um we're trying to sort of take more
of a playful almost absurdist take on on
that particular moment in history uh
very much inspired also by our love for
like the cool
Espionage
mythologies from the 50s 60s obviously
Bond being one
example um and you know Collective love
for sidescrolling games uh I played a
ton of sidescrolling action games as a
kid growing up I think you've seen a lot
of really awesome sides scrolling games
in recent years um you know Shadow
complex Mar the ninja so this is very
much our contribution to that now if any
of you guys are watching this on
gamespot's Twitch Channel feel free to
join us in the chat room and I'll take
your questions live on the air um so
this is something I asked you a while
ago when I actually saw the game before
E3 but this type of setting it's not
something that you see very often in
video games it's so so much more often
the modern day Sage setting but you guys
are going back in time to the Cold War
what is it about that era that appealed
to you guys
so I wonder if part of that is because
uh I I remember the Cold War and that's
probably putting an age on me a little
bit um but it's really um it it's kind
of a hits on a lot of levels like it's
this really crazy intense moment in
history where you had these two sort of
fundamentally opposed
ideologies um facing off against each
other on the world stage which kind of
from a video game perspective sounds
like a a sort of a setting that you
would create for a video game if it
didn't already exist um and I think that
basically um we were really inspired by
the the stylizations of the fiction that
was coming out of that era um you know
everyone kind of knows Bond and are
familiar with sort of the Shan conry era
Bond um but it was something that U
myself and Mark who's the art director
on the project um you know he'd worked
at Pixar for a number of years so he'd
worked on um The Incredibles you
definitely get a little bit of that Vibe
here you can see that influence in it
for sure um but it's also like The
Incredibles was a a film that was
definitely riffing on that sort of
Golden Age Era of superheroes and
touching on a lot of the the visual
stylizations and trappings of that era
um so I think kind of on a lot of levels
like there was a lot of visually really
awesome interesting stuff going on
during the 50s and 60s era that we
wanted to take as a rapper um you know
the spage Thrillers of that time were
sort of very Fantastical and cool um and
the setting itself it feels like we're
sort of distant enough from it now that
you can be a little bit more playful um
uh yeah so it was kind of hitting on all
those levels okay so the game being a 2D
Sid scroller although it's kind of like
the the angle has changed up a little
bit here but generally speaking it is a
presented from the 2D perspective and
that's a that's perspective that you can
do a lot of things with you can do the
real jumping heavy platform style games
you can do the real Combat heavy Metroid
Vania style games how would you describe
you know the general sense of how this
game plays um well you can see here it
has a little bit of elements of all like
it's not a heavy platformer but there is
platform navigation in the level uh it's
uh it's got pretty much core to the game
is the the action and stealth component
um one of the things we wanted to do
with the game was was make it have a
stealth game but be fairly light on the
stealth side like not make a game that
forces you to play stealthy so if you
want to um you can sort of running gun
uh Grace has been playing with a silence
pistol here which is sort of the perfect
stealth weapon but um she can switch to
a machine gun Q
[Laughter]
Gracey you know so certainly there's
areas where it gets more combat
intensive um one of the things about the
the game system that uh we think is
pretty cool is uh at the top of the
screen in the middle of the UI you see
there's a a Defcon level that's what
that number represents um that's the
Devcon level for the the side that
you're currently
of rating which is the
Socialists um that's set of four right
so that's a number that increases based
on your activity in the game so if you
get spot by security cameras if guys see
you they'll get on the radio and radio
in um if you die while you're playing
the level you get a pretty fast restart
but that Devcon also goes up um you need
to keep an eye on that and if it gets
too high if it gets above one then a
countdown starts that's the launch
countdown which is what your you're
trying to prevent and at that point
you've got to run and get to the end of
the level and that the way that system
works means that generally like uh it
rewards you from playing stealthily
because if people don't notice you
they're not getting on the radio uh you
can generally clear rooms more
effectively um if you've able to take a
few guys out before everyone's noticed
you um but at the same time like uh you
can get into just a big firefight so
here Grace is probably going to blow up
a few explosives M hint
hint got this big red they were not
quite in range uh so now you can kind of
see it's more kicked off uh the action
ah there's like um guys with RPGs um so
she's died now you can see that's how
the Cold War ended well she's still in
it the Cold War isn't over yet so uh the
death comes at three now um but she can
kind of re-enter um it's designed to be
fairly pick up and play um easy to get
into uh yeah I'm trying to think did I
completely lose the thread of your
question no no no no you're you're doing
just fine I'm a little bit more focused
on how Grace is going to approach this
one right now right well she's takeen
out a few guys as that little guy
hanging off the platform
there um throw that grade back so he's
on the radio now so you can see that's
causing the alert level to go up okay um
so sometimes in the game you'll be
playing uh you'll be sort of picking
your spots taking guys out and then
somebody else gets on the radio and at
that point you you kind of need to
adjust your strategy and make sure you
either take him out if you can or
sometimes you'll actually have to go
path to where he is and take him out as
well oh see if you can stealth kill this
guy oh he saw me saw you a little itchy
trigger finger there so the thing you
mentioned earlier that you're seeing as
Grace is playing is there the the use of
cover um and camer perspective shift
right um and so that's one of the things
that we we wanted to try and do
something that was a bit different that
built on the the sort of sides scrolling
genre um and because we're building the
game in full 3d uh that's something that
we it's funny so during development it's
one of these things where um we were
sort of experimenting messing around we
already had this notion that you'll go
into cover you'll be hidden from enemies
um but then yeah it was one of those
things where someone was like oh let me
just adjust the camera oh that's cool
that looks very cinematic and we were
and so we were like oh cool we have like
cinematic Viewpoint that that feels good
um but then we started thinking about
well wait that could really alter the
way the gameplay experience like if
you're popping into cover and now um it
switched into this 3D view you have more
of a 3D pop and shoot aim take guys out
right okay um so we felt like that was a
nice way to sort of mix it up um and
we'd wanted to think about how to make a
cover mechanic work in aidid scroller
so uh so I'm guessing by all that stuff
that we unlocked just now and the
schematics and everything there is kind
of a meta game that links the overall
structure yeah so one of the things
that's interesting is uh if you skip
through this grace and get to this
screen this is your mission select
screen uh when you're playing the game
here let me just try for a sec I'll just
show this um so see how seamlessly we do
that yeah teamwork you guys are
experienced veterans so uh so this is
how you choose what mission you want to
take in the game and you have two sides
you've got the Socialists on one side
you've got the imperialists on the other
side um and they each have their own
separate Devcon level so um the way that
Grace played in the last level that
devcom has now climbed to three so uh
you might want to switch to the
imperialist side that has a lower devcom
um the the thing that's key to
understand is that it it's a game the
way you progress in the game is by
collecting all the launch plans um both
sides are trying to uh build a rocket to
launch launch a nuclear strike at the
Moon blow up the moon you're thinking
that's crazy you're trying to stop them
honestly that sounds a little crazy I
try to stop that too CRA so let's try
and stop it so um yeah so basically
let's pick the imperialist side uh I
will hand it back to you Grace yeah want
to Grace do you want to just give a
quick primer here yeah so at the
beginning of every Mission or before you
head into a mission you want to load up
on all the gear and Tech that'll help
you get through it um you know lives
intact Defcon as low as possible and so
there's various um weapons that we have
so I've unlocked quite a few already as
you can see um you've got to manage your
ammo so you'll have to buy ammo between
missions or find it in levels and ammo
lockers um so you can see I've unlocked
like a cool assault rifle haven't
unlocked this one yet um shotgun
atomizer shotgun sounds pretty effective
AIC the atomizer um let's see some other
ones I've bought here I don't have
enough money for these unfortunately the
go if you go back up one the dart
persuaders one of my favorites uh the
it's a it's definitely a skill weapon
you have to master how to use it but if
you manage to shoot an enemy with that
you can Bas you can kind of repurpose
them um and get them working on your
side um yeah let's just jump into the
level yeah sure oh one thing before we
jump in so formulas are really key um
the levels are getting harder and harder
the more you play and so you might need
a little help so maybe you want some
armor you know you'll take less damage
you might need some help with Defcon so
this one is super useful um you know
instead of jumping into that level with
the Defcon of three maybe if I equip
this it'll be four instead which
basically buys me an extra life um in
essence uh so we've got all sorts of
cool stuff I I like silent Runner
because I like um running up against or
running up behind guys and taking them
out silently MH that's super helpful if
they don't hear your footsteps because
normally they hear you as you're
running but uh yeah let's let's uh
actually
buy let's buy the silent Runner yeah I
had a great comment in the chat room
from Dijon ketchup who says the moon has
been keeping the tides in check for too
long absolutely I 100% agree with that
the moon's got it coming too many
romantic evenings have occurred because
of the Moon full moon uh too many
werewolves yep uh there's also that uh
Nazi Moonbase if you played Wolfenstein
oh that's true yeah that's true you can
never be too careful the moons had a bad
year in video games right
yeah so um while Grace is playing uh
again one of the things we wanted to
really hit with this was make a game
that was of you know fun playful it's
not meant to be a realistic reenactment
of the Cold War uh e even the two sides
um you know we we've got the
imperialists and the Socialists and
that's sort of riffing on the the common
insults that would often get passed
around and thrown at each
side attention Lieutenant will be giving
a lecture on the Pres of pre fluids now
are the levels generally structured in a
way where you're pretty much always
moving left to right or is there ever a
sense of backtracking right good
question um so uh one of the things
we've talked about this before um the
levels are constructed using procedural
elements okay so uh every level is
constructed um where all the different
rooms come together and knitted together
in in a different order
uh generally that means that you you are
moving from left to right um there are
uh branching sort of side rooms where
you can take an elevator go down there's
not one in this level um so you can
deviate from the path um but generally
you always know that uh your ultimate
objective is to get to the end of the
level on which is on the right um that's
where the launch computer is for the
rocket
so if you do get that launch countdown
start you kind of have to stop thinking
about exploration and stealth and just
gun it and try and get to there before
the countdown goes down okay um but
again
like getting uh getting the launch plans
is key um so as you're playing through
the game uh looking for the computers
that have a launch plans um they're
always going to be in different places
that that's part of the procedural
system system so even if you uh a room
might seem familiar um what where where
things are placed where the enemies are
what the enemies have that's all uh
changing um and the game also has uh
exploration um so there are lots of
little secret nooks and crannies uh to
reward the player that that looks around
and wants to find
stuff or twitch chat is engaged in a
very exciting discussion about how much
they hate the moon but a reminder if you
guys do have any questions feel free to
submit them yeah and you are uh trying
to protect the moon as a as an agent of
counter so counter is definitely in the
Pro Moon c pro Moon yeah that's good
that's
good show oh um do the do you want to
show the uh cover switching gr oh yeah
so you've
got one sec guy's throwing grenades at
me right here so this pesky guys on the
radio I'll take them out um so we've got
all sorts of cover objects sprinkled
throughout the level that you can take
cover behind obviously spare you from
gunfire you can reload and shoot one uh
Advanced Pro tip is that you can hold
down the direction that you want to uh
roll into and hold down Circle to exit
cover there and you can roll two from
cover can do it while you're running
yeah and that's a good Pro tip for um
typically when you enter a new room a
good strategy is uh look around see if
there's some cover a good hiding Point
nearby uh using the dive roll holding
that while you're running is a good way
to quickly get into cover and buy
yourself time to scope out the
environment see where the bad guys are
and figure out your strategy so one of
the uh one of the common questions we're
getting in the chat right now is why
exactly are trying to why indeed well so
it's interesting uh on the one hand uh
it's a kind of outlandish concept that's
sort of inspired by if you think of your
typical bond plot right there's always
some megalomaniac that's like you know
I'm going to create this laser beam
that's going to melt the polar ice caps
and destroy the world unless I get a
million dollars whatever like but it's
some crazy plan that you have to stop um
and we sort of flipped it in our game
where the super superpowers are the
super villains um and the other
interesting nugget of information and
people can Google this right now is that
the US uh did develop a plan to launch a
nuclear strike at the Moon uh it was a
plan they developed in 1958 MH uh this
was when the US was falling behind the
Soviets in the Space Race So the Soviets
had just launched butnik you know that's
orbiting around the earth they're like
oh we have to catch up what are we going
to do so it's like hey guys let's
brainstorm Solutions here basically if
if we can't get to the moon nobody can
well yeah and I I I think that to give
them some credit they probably they're
probably their plan was not to destroy
the moon they were like if we could just
leave a big Den right um and that that
would be a good way to show the Soviets
like hey you know we've got some prowess
we're back on top um so uh I mean both
both sides In fairness Space Race was
originated in the German scientists that
went to both sides after World War II
yep that is another the German V2 rocket
program absolutely there's a little
history lesson for you guys right we
actually have all sorts of historical
facts sprinkled into the the loading
screen so it's not just gameplay tips as
usual got a little it's one of the
things and you know um so I remember as
a kid right like growing up some
elements of the Cold War and you're at
that time you're looking at these things
that adults are talking about and you
think oh adults they're supposed to be
smart and you know mature and what they
say goes yeah and you and and so you
start to get aware of like these uh
leaders political leaders on both sides
just kind of threatening oh if you do
this like we're going to launch
thousands of nuclear missiles and
destroy the world and it's like that
always seemed absolutely insane
um and as a kid of the absurdity of that
um and I think that's probably something
that has certainly stayed with me a
little bit as I get older is like you
shouldn't assume that there's any crazy
fictional uh plot of a movie that's so
outlandish that some government agency
somewhere hasn't already thought
about um what was one of the other ones
we found when we were looking up the
acoustic Kitty oh that was my favorite
so there was a plan to um I mean there
were various plans on both sides right
so um I got it I think the CIA had a
proposal to outfit cats
with um you know little transmitters and
microphones so that they could go and
EES drop near the
Kremlin and uh yeah that didn't work
because the uh the Prototype cat as it
were supposedly got ran over when it
across the street somehow cat turns out
cats are not super Cooperative yeah they
don't follow Direction owns a cat you'd
be like how did they not have a
conversation with a cat
owner all right I think you're pretty
clear
yep uh
think po
cat getting some good cat discussion in
this chat room right
now
all right see how I did not great
admittedly I died
once okay so the cash you earn here is
pretty key particularly as it gets more
difficult um you're going to need that
cash to buy more weapons ammo um the
formulas which are perks that are
onetime use so those are pretty key as
well wonder if we can uh pick a
different
which side do you want to do Grace
imperialist or socialist what are your
choices well I just played a u uh
imperialist Mission Rian slip uh so yeah
I probably want to steer clear this for
now I could lower the Defcon by dealing
with officers which are unique yeah type
of NPC that's a cool feature which we I
guess we'll describe that if we see it
in a game there's an officer in this
level as well oh yeah let's do the
social
social uh kind of want to buy a new
weapon I died once so I probably need to
up my Firepower somehow looks like I can
only afford this guy
though that and I could probably reup on
some
ammo yeah the silence pistol is super
useful you unlock that pretty early in
the game um and uh yeah it it's um if
you want to play stealthy it's
definitely your first plan of attack um
it's not as powerful as the regular
pistol so if you do end up in a
firefight yeah switch to a different
weapon uh how much can you play
non-lethally in the game if that's kind
of how you want to go about it is that
like a viable tactic it would be super
hard uh you could we could always say
that the uh diplomatic pistols F
fires tongue twister fires a
tranquilizer doubts but that would be a
lie um there are there is a tranquilizer
weapon in the game that you could use um
so that would be one option
um yeah uh I think that um the the
challenge one of the challenges we've
built around the game are uh like how
stealthy do I want to be for example so
um there are bonuses that you get from
building up of stealth chains and and
that's actually a really fun way to play
as as I'm playing the game uh you'll
you'll see uh these stealth chains like
oh take a guy out with a um with a
silencer or sneak up behind take someone
and you'll get a multiplier um and it's
fun to see how many you can get in a
level I think that Chris on our team has
the record okay and he has got
43 stealth kills in a row which is
insane uh um I would love to see if
anyone can beat that once the game comes
out I'm sure somebody will I'm sure they
will well if they do they should uh take
a screenshot and um post it on Twitter
uh Dynamite because we would want to see
that all right we want to shame Chris
basically um I suppose there's a few
other details about the game that I
could share uh so it's it's going to be
coming out uh on PlayStation 4
PlayStation 3 and Vita uh and it's going
to be a crossby game so even if you
don't have your PlayStation 4 yet and
you're planning to buy it um buy this
game and you'll be able to play it on
that platform as well as your your
others um it also has a cross- save
functionality so uh you can put the game
down um switch to V when you're on the
road you can continue your progress um
or your unlocks so the blueprints uh the
formulas that you've collected in the
game get shared across all the devices
okay yeah so that's super useful is
there any V VA specific touch input
stuff the only thing we've done there is
is the menus the menu navigation also
works with with touch um we wanted to
try and sort of harmonize as much as
possible The Experience um even the
shoulder buttons uh on the console
versions uh we we only use um sort of
aim and fire which we tried not to max
out all the buttons um again wanting it
to be accessible people can pick up and
play
um so I see a question uh from Affinity
about skills to upgrade um and so that
that is the formulas the formulas are
perks and those are the sort of boosters
that you upgrade as you play through the
game so so um playing a level uh
collecting formulas in the game which
you find in the safes and there's a safe
just up there um that's how you
essentially get acquire things that that
make your skills
[Laughter]
better po I dove out of coverage I have
to make sure I didn't so one thing we
reminded ourselves before we went into
this game session is
like we've been playing this for like
probably thousands and thousands of
hours by now um just testing it so we
were trying to remind ourselves like to
not um play in the most optimal way
possible so um so we can show things
like the countown right things like that
so I think now would be a good time hint
H for Grace
to take a few hits for the team karate
my gamer cred I know well and you know
that that explosive crate is so
tantilizing there I think that you kind
of have to do the nasty on that oh yeah
uhoh can you actually shoot that rocket
while it's you can Total Advanced move
uh yeah it's a good like sometimes a
good strategy you'll be in a big room
with a a guy fing the RPG and so you can
time shooting the RPGs to clear out a
bunch of guys that are in front of them
death cons at two
y running a low on ammo oh if that
camera spots you that would make your
death Conta go up hint hint hint
hint almost there take the elevator yeah
yeah so this is an example of one of
these branching paths that David had
talked about so some levels have
elevators some don't it's all part of
the procedural
system but they usually have some sort
of
now juicy reward at the end little bit
of combat to get there though so you
have to balance the risk
right oh shotgun hav used a shotgun yet
Grace I have oh you have yeah I think
you used it at one point on a guy who
was about 6 Ines away from you yeah he
kind of flew across the room didn't he
he had a real bad day after
that guys out target practice so the
further you go in the game as you're
completing more levels the difficulty
does ramp up uh new guards get
introduced that are tougher uh with
different weapons um we we picked up we
sort of jumped into a relative midpoint
here so you were already seeing guys
with grenade launchers rocket launchers
there's shotgun dudes um you'll get more
Elite guys later on as well yeah there
even the guards with helmets so you
can't just you know head shot them and
you got to head shot them twice actually
mhm be the best way to take them out so
you described this uh very early on into
the stream but for anybody who's just
tuning in we've got some questions in
the chat what exactly does the Defcon
level do when it gets gets higher so uh
the Defcon level is is kind of uh if you
think of it like a a oh officer sorry
I'm just going to take a side note here
so uh here you can see there's an
officer in the room uh officers are key
to lowering the de C when you're in a
level um and the way you do that is
they're they're kind of a cowardly Bunch
you've got to be take ever take all the
other enemies out uh cuz he's going to
be fighting you right now but don't kill
him um because once he's the last guy
standing he will
surrender put your G at him wow he
surrendered immediately there was no
question in that guy's mind whether or
not to surrender he wants to live to
fight another day um so uh in terms of
the
Defcon um it the the the the increase is
that you're you're closer to that launch
countdown essentially that is the the
difference and and I think the way that
that changes the way you play the game
is uh you the closer it is to that that
you have to just start being a lot more
careful be stealthy try not to get
yourself into a situation where the
launch countdown triggers especially if
you're too far away from the end of a
level
M we should probably show uh what
happens when the launch countdown starts
yeah sure yeah yeah take a look getting
perilously close to a failure there the
officer helped me out though thanks
officer but I'll take one for the team
here and uh yeah so now we've got the
devc cons at two on both sides um but
you can see here there's three officers
in that level um so you would have a
good opportun Unity to lower the Defcon
if you can play skillfully and get them
to surrender the other side only has one
uh but there are more launch plans um
but let's do that one Grace cuz we
actually want to um trigger the launch
countdown all right let's see what
happens I see a question here oh there
was already an answer multiplatform or
or console exclusive so yeah the other
game so we didn't mention the fact that
there is also a mobile version um that's
going to be on Android and iOS and um
that game is the same core gameplay um
it's actually Something That We're super
excited about um we you're you're
playing as a as a traine agent for
counter and in that game you're going
into just socialist uh bases um but the
same core gameplay is this is stealth
side scrolling game uh and it's a game
that doesn't use Virtual sticks we have
this really interesting gesture based
control okay uh that I think people will
be really interested in checking
out run me over at no virtual sticks
yeah well it's one of those things I
mean I'm sure you people talk about this
adium but um when you're playing on a
iPhone or any touch device when you
throw a virtual stick on there you're
basically reminding the player that
they're not playing a console game like
just imagine if you were at home right
now or if you had a v um you know you
could have the full benefits of playing
with a control pad and so we really
wanted to make approach it from the
point of view of like how would someone
play a sidescrolling action game where
touch was their only
input scrb back in the chat says nice to
see the devs are watching the chat for
questions I'm almost terrified that the
devs are watching the chat for questions
because you guys can be a real Wild
Bunch but you actually are pretty well
behaved today so I I appreciate
that all right so so we're trying to
raise that death con level right yeah
trying to take some damage Grace stop
playing so well Grace what are you doing
I can't help
it this is against all instincts
here I think we might have to uh save
you from yourself I am taking some
damage though let's get head back up
getting derailed
here oh here's a huge room some of these
rooms are really you know sort of
multi-art areas Mak can be quite
challenging
um typically I'd enter and try to be as
discreet as possible trying to sneak
around oh no okay we're at one let's see
if we can make it happen
oh
it there's just that one guy there's
still another there's plenty more going
to have to do an intervention at this
point Gamers Anonymous oh there's some
guys here uhoh he's on the radio yeah
I'll let him chitchat with his buddies
engaging now you can see here the defc
is actually raising oh yeah the longer
he's on the radio
right all right take him out now
okay now can I get to the exit in time
about to stop the
launch so you can see there's an arrow
helps guide your way so if you're
getting into a little bit of a panic
about where to go hopefully it'll help
you make your way to the end so normally
when when you're in these rooms there's
different areas you might want to
explore um in secret that you just don't
at this time don't really want to take
the risk should just get to the exit
yeah pretty heavily guarded take
that Rusty shotgun uh mle 1987 is asking
is this a downloadable or retail game it
is downloadable yep be on PSN coming out
in the
summer uh as soon as we finish this
we're going back to work to just uh make
a few final tweaks
and
yeah you see the top the clock's winding
down I wasn't even paying attention
you're actually going to fail I'm
actually going to fail this Mission oh
no a goodbye
Moon goodbye Moon it was nice knowing
you
however
you can continue There is a continue you
get another bite of the
Cherry so um yep so you've lost of of
all the progress from that level um and
now uh you have two new fresh levels to
choose from okay um so you do have a
chance to get back in the game mhm okay
right like I still out of all my gear
all my money um and it's interesting so
originally the original implementation
of this that would have been game over
oh okay you have to start all the way
from the beginning again right which
seemed like a good idea at the
time um but one of the things we do the
process of of fining the game is once
you've got the whole game there we do a
lot of um play testing right where we
get people in who've never played the
game before MH which is super important
cuz you can imagine like we know where
all the nooks and crannies are we've
been playing this game for so long we
have like old eyes like we cannot
necessarily see stuff M um and once we
got people who' never played the game
before playing playing the game they'd
be playing through having fun ah this is
awesome countdown starts ah no no and as
soon as that game over was came up and
they had to start all over again um
people were like super frustrated and
mad at us like literally mad at us for
this um and so it is one of those things
where um you know you kind of have to
trust um what people are telling you the
experience people have playing your game
is very important um and so um you know
we also we had a version of this game
last year that I look back at it now oh
like man it was so
early you know it's just really amazing
to kind of see like I've been making
games for a while but it still amazes me
to see how as you're as you're building
this thing and all the different pieces
are coming together how um how things
can just suddenly click into place and
start working and then you look back at
older versions of the game and you're
like
wow um a question so there's a question
from Eminem stranger about what sort of
play time are we looking at um so if
you're a skilled player you could play
through the game on the normal setting
um you could potent potentially win in
about 3 to 4 hours um uh after that if
you uh there's more advanced levels that
you can unlock um and the key thing is
that because the game plays procedurally
uh e even if you're playing on the same
difficulty you're not going to go back
and go oh here's the same game that
we're playing from level one so we're
hoping that that gives people a lot of
replayability um there's also high score
leaderboards where you compete beating
against your PSN friends for a high
score um and something we're we're
actually not connected to PSN right now
um but there's also uh a rival spy
feature excuse me and how the Rival spy
feature works is that um as you're
playing through the game it'll pick a
score that one of your friends uh got um
and it'll ask you to beat it as a
challenge and if you can beat that
player's score then on the next level
there's a down agent that you have look
for and find and if you find that then
you get
bonuses so we' got little things like
that in there that you think people will
get really into even when they finish
the game did you guys do procedurally
generated levels because you wanted to
add replayability or was it for a
different
purpose gosh
uh it was it was definitely uh an
example of something that we felt would
have help replayability so we're we're a
small team we have 12 people okay um but
we actually we're only 12 people now
like when we started this game we were
three people and then for a long time we
were at five and what that meant was um
one level designer one environment
artist and so it's kind of like how are
we going to build enough content just
physically build enough
content uh in this game that people will
be able to have fun and procedural is
something that really interested us uh
you had a lot of really awesome games
like spelunk that were out at that time
and so uh we wanted to think about how
to incorporate that into this game um
you know I look at games now like no
man's Sky which I know a lot of people
were just blown away yeah by E3 and I
can tell you I mean that's not just game
Gamers like everybody who makes games
people are making games everyone's
talking about that
um I I think um the procedural aspects
of this
game uh I really like how it works in
terms of you never know what you're
going to get you never know what enemies
you're going to face so you're not like
oh I I know the patterns I know where
everything is um I think it's a good uh
sort of foundation uh blog um with the
the way the levels get constructed
together uh you will learn um the the
architecture of levels so from the
navigation of the levels you can build
up a familiarity with the levels so in
that respect it's not I I tend to
describe it as it it has procedural
systems um it doesn't it's not a pure
procedural the way I would describe a No
Man's
Sky
yeah um that does allow us a level of
control as well though right like it
allows us to make sure that we really
Crush CED the spaces that the player is
moving through oh there's a secret there
Grace oh yeah there's enemies
here that man did not want you totally
uh put you off your game yeah I just
wanted to show that as an example that
there are lots of little nuggets around
the world yeah that will reward
exploration you're back get deathcon one
oh yeah you're super high and you're
almost dead and so if you die that
countdown is going to start again oh but
there's an officer who's there ready up
engage thought about surrendering but
now he's got
his there we go no there he is yay can I
Surrender probably
not can't have them keep blowing up the
moon hey go in and show that uh secret
area that I lovingly
crafted we'll give away this one so
remember this one hey
woohoo little secret area with a little
few more goodies down here if you can
take that guy
out follow
him that iy really thought that helmet
would save him he was wrong not with
that move not so much there's a formula
that uh you can earn and buy that will
allow you to head shot guys even when
they have armor you can basically
armored piercing okay take them out
um yeah formulas definitely help out the
harder the more the difficulty increases
there's all sort of like knobs and dials
and that you know kind of play with the
underlying
systems I always love that part of video
games where you have to plant a
breaching charge that sets off an
explosive but because you want the game
to keep going you just kind of lean out
of the way like
even though there's an explosion going
off let me just Flinch slightly here and
it's totally fine yeah yeah we're
good yeah he's wearing a tactical
turtleneck it's all right right oh yeah
he's all armored
up I think we you kind of get away with
a lot more when you're kind of doing a
very stylized game as well right like
there's not that weird logic disconnect
like wait I I look like a super
realistic dude in a realistic world
yeah I mean the art style is Al
obviously something that draws people in
um we also like to have fun with our
game like we have all sorts of funny
posters and um backstory unlockable
stuff that you can uncover throughout
the course of the game and it's just you
know we're trying to have fun this is
not a super serious War Thriller right
it is maybe it's to these guys maybe
they find it very serious but I mean
we're all just having fun this is our
sort of light-hearted absurd take on
Cold War
right yeah it was kind of cool um
Wolfenstein is a game that I've been
playing a lot recently uh I love that
game uh and it's interesting cuz it has
there's like a lot that's absurd about
it right um but at the same time there's
some pretty uh sort of heavy undertones
oh yeah in that game as well and it's
one of those things like I think that
game
can at their core be fun not take
themselves too seriously but I think you
can either say something about the world
or have a point of view about things um
you know to me that makes a game more
interesting
um again not being super preachy right
about
it that on the
radio
Wolfenstein is interesting too because
it kind of gives you a glimpse at what
would happen if the Cold War never
happened Germany won and there was no US
versus the USSR
right oh I took him out I was wrong yeah
I think it's it's
interesting uhoh countdown timer on oh
well she's in should be
okay let's try and make it this time
shall
we I got no no pressure but I think this
is is all we have time for on the Stream
So if you don't make it to the end uhoh
have to do without the moon yeah then
we're going to say goodbye to the Moon
right I I've got faith in
you oh the music is something that we
think is pretty awesome it was composed
by Jesse Harlem who was someone that we
worked with uh LucasArts so a bunch of
us on the team worked at LucasArts um
John and the company worked on the same
team um and Jesse who was the composer
so at LucasArts he was pretty much like
the John Williams guy so he probably
composed like more John
williamses music in his lifetime than
Joan Williams did just because the
amount that you need for all the
different video games over the years so
getting to work on something like this
was a real change of pace and very
refreshing and um it's one of the things
that been nice for us um you know
everyone was super sad when Luke starts
closed down but from that you know there
was a lot of super talented passionate
people that all kind of spread out and
want to do their own thing and we're
also still finding ways to work together
yeah it looks like you guys are doing
something really cool with counter spy
and I know this is a game that I'm
excited for since I got to check out
check it out before E3 but it's uh it's
not that far off right you said it's
coming out this summer very close summer
so when when is the end of summer summer
uh I would say end of August maybe maybe
mid September okay let's hope so guess
we should head back to the office finish
that all right there we go no pressure
the clock is ticking um all right well
David Grace I appreciate you guys
swinging by showing us counter yeah
no problem thanks having us can you go
ahead and remind everybody uh what
platforms it's coming out for yep uh
Playstation 4 PlayStation 3 PlayStation
Vita uh Cross by so buy for one get it
on all also has cross- save
functionality and there's going to be a
mobile version that that ties into those
main console versions as well all right
sounds good there you guys have it that
was your look at counter spy thanks a
lot for watching right
bye